what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
clip that one of my follow
followers sent me via instagram titled
how much should
men earn so if i had to guess i'm gonna
guess this is a clip talking about
girls unrealistic expectations
with how much guys should earn this is
just my guess without even watching it
um before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos as you guys
know i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers
so each and every one of you are helping
me get to that goal
all right let's see
uh we're gonna start here and work our
way back that way standards of men
um i guess we could start with how much
they have to earn and how tall
um i would say like
five seven like i would want you to be
minimum
um just because like i like looking up
at you i don't know
how tall are you better i'm five two and
a half okay okay five two one yeah
oh my god standing right now
all right so uh and how much they have
to earn for you um
i wouldn't even say like i mean
i would prefer someone who doesn't work
a nine to five that's how i feel about
the topic like if that makes sense like
i'd rather you work for me i just
wouldn't want to my dad worked about
about every single day like
six six or five days a week and i just
didn't like that
i would want someone that i could
actually spend time with isn't like nine
to five nine to six like
i don't know so uh yeah the problem is
though they work
extra hard so they were 80 hours yeah my
dad was an entrepreneur
and i guarantee he worked more than like
any guy with a nine to five so i think
she's gonna get the opposite result
and what she thinks for less time though
than the nine to five
like for less amount of time i don't
know what businesses you guys are
hold on hold on the average entrepreneur
works
double what they work on a job but they
may not work night to fight them and
work
but like seven times you would work like
at home or like you could work on
vacation like you could work wherever
you are yeah i like the freedom freedom
yeah okay that's definitely true we were
definitely able to do like a lot of
family vacations because
my parents both were like in charge of
their own schedule so i could see what
she's saying there
for sure okay but you're avoiding the
most important question uh how much
i'm surprised so she was five two she
wouldn't date a guy that's five
below five seven even a guy that's five
five it's like three inches taller
how much on cause women have standards
here i you guys have brought up
standards quite a bit here
um i would say like i want you to make
like i would say
at least sixty five thousand a year okay
okay
this actually isn't super crazy
like her requirements this isn't like
i've seen girls on this show ask for
like
half a million i've even had say that
that's
heard girl say that that's like broke so
that's actually not crazy 5k
i mean like obviously like more like it
would be like
great but remember give us what you want
though now you're mine you've got to be
politically close
yeah um i mean see all the girls looking
at like crazy like 65 kids i need some
mcdonald's tonight
how old are they
if the guys like comes right out of
college 65k that's not like
like that's a decent um i would say i
mean like a hundred thousand if you make
that a year
like that's very easy six figures okay
thank you for telling us the truth
okay here we go how tall how much money
do they have to earn and what other
standards do you have
i would prefer six feet uh-huh okay
just because i'm super short wait
how tall are you don't worry about it
wait because i think you're short of
hurt right
yeah yeah you're six feet high
i lie god damn it i think i even lied on
my driver's license
i definitely didn't miss me okay so uh
continuing on we got to stay focused
here all right so
uh six feet tall how much they have to
earn for you
um like eight figures or more
eight it's bigger
he's got to make seven figures is a
millionaire so you're saying he's got to
make at least 10 million
for you yeah i want a billionaire
if i can bring money home if i can bring
money home he has to bring money home
are you a millionaire yourself i doubt
it that was like there's
no way she makes so much money but my
[ __ ] should be if i do if i'm doing it
oh my god look at that girl's reaction
[Music]
oh my god everything else then i'm
pretty sure that hey bigger [ __ ]
okay hey figure so they got to make 10
million at least okay enough
what about you no cap slap okay so i'm
like five two so i really don't care
if my guy is like 5 11 and uh that's
cool
i don't really care as long as his 5 11
and up okay yeah as long as his morals
and his values is good i don't really
care
okay also the same thing with the money
like as long as he's a hustler he's
ambitious
i really don't care how much you make
just make that money and just make sure
you're supporting both of us because i'm
gonna do the same so no hold on hold on
you
it definitely does matter because you
broke off some pretty serious
relationships for the money so we need
to know this no no no it wasn't because
of the money it was more because i
just made more and it was supporting
more
exactly so money was a direct route
you're right you're right
yeah we keep it real on this on this
podcast we're not
out about this politically correct yes
how much you have to earn for you bare
minimum for you to take them seriously
and not break up with him after a
five-year relationship i mean i make
like 60k a year so okay
so he's got to make at least at least
that so you gotta you gotta you gotta be
even with me
because at the end of the day
relationships are partnerships and
they're they should be equal and they
should be able to so you said earlier
that you're happy with being okay other
than
the last girl they haven't been
completely insane
so far we'll see what the rest of them
do like saying
60 like that's not bad single unless the
guy unless the guy brings something to
the table so what would make you say you
know what
i'll i'll date this guy seriously i'll
take him seriously if he makes me happy
from an earning standpoint bare minimum
he has to make equal to me okay so
you're okay with 60.
yeah you'll marry a guy absolutely okay
it just has he just hasn't made me happy
that's all that that's all that matters
to me at the end of the day what if i'm
a drug dealer
um that is like another story for
another day sir oh okay
oh no oh she's dated a drug dealer
you could tell look at the way she
answered that question there's no way
there's no way she did what about you
what were the questions again
otherwise she would have just said no
please pay attention
please pay attention it is uh the
question was um
what are your standards of men uh
earning potential height and something
else
because a lot of women brought up
standards and you know because you said
oh most guys aren't worthy
they're you know they're emotionally
manipulative which is what you said
so yeah what would what standards would
they have to have would you have on
these men to be happy with them
honestly i just want someone to return
the energy i give them
um earning wise uh as long as they have
the same
hustle or like the same ambition like
she said
um to match mine because i'm a very
ambitious person
and i have a lot of goals i want to see
that from my partner too you know what i
mean
um and height i don't know as long as
he's not shorter than me i'm straight
that's true i i like the vibes
not the outside you know what i mean
very ambiguous answer but okay
no worries uh let's continue on okay
because you said as long as they match
the energy with me or anything we need
more tangible
numbers like something more tangible
like okay you know
because i get that like that stuff she
probably just means like common interest
politically correct answer if you ten if
you ask a girl hey what are you liking a
guy they're gonna tell you the you know
the pageant answers
a nice guy i want a nice guy that
listens to me and i like my energy and
you know
what i can build with you know like oh
yeah good boy you know i like some bs
like that
so um do you have anything else you want
to add to that or no
um no okay
okay sure he knows what time it is
don't grill me right here we're good
okay uh i'm gonna say six foot
turn it off
i can make a better impression of that
anyway i got a better one stupid go
ahead
that's what she wearing about stop
talking thank you
oh she's giving it back
i bet they're about to paint her as like
super sassy but like he was kind of he's
been kind of rude to him
can i answer your lovely question thank
you you want to stay on topic but look
at you
no i'm listening go ahead damn i kind of
like
okay so six foot and between like 70 and
100k
like there six figures
okay yeah but or less but 70 and above
so i know that you know
we're we're comfortable we're okay okay
okay
and uh anything else no taller than you
yeah i'm really tall so you gotta be
taller than me that's all
oh she's not even i guess that is pretty
tall i'm five eleven i'm
like almost six foot so
like i think a five nine is like almost
short i'm a giant
[Music]
um he has the weaver 6'3
and uh financially depends if he's under
30
if he's under 30 um anywhere from 50 to
100k
if he's over 30 300k and i thought i was
bad
we're talking well she's going to say 10
million you know
she said 300 dollars she's keeping it
real yeah is that canadian or u.s just
so that people know
it doesn't matter well there's a
significant difference yeah but
you know um canadian preferably
usd but okay so i wouldn't say 300 000
u.s
um cool
damn that's pretty high the first one to
mention standards so let's uh
well if we're talking about money and
height um bare minimum
75 a year um heights 5 8 and up
um as far as my other standards
um substance he has to have substance
about him
can you define substance what does that
mean like i can have a conversation with
you like if you know me i like to talk
i like to have debates like as far as
like things going on in the world
and stuff like that and so if you don't
if you're not aka she wants someone
political
socially or politically aware yeah it's
enough see i said it before she even had
to say it
okay so you want to fight your man
that's great no not a fight no no but
like talk about what's going on in those
days and not just like sit there and
stare at each other like
all right fair enough cool all right so
i generally just like somebody taller
than me um it's not hard to beat i'm 5'4
um and then as far as like income i mean
i'm just going to go ahead and shoot it
straight with like at least
100k i mean 100 000 yeah 100k um brain
fart
whatever um and then uh
okay i wanna know how old these girls
are
well like if a dude's like 24 he makes
60k that's really not bad
like that's pretty good it's probably
above average as far as everything else
uh honestly i like somebody that's like
interesting like
somebody that they walk in a room and
you just like notice them not because
they're like
the prettiest or like the xyz like
because they're interesting like maybe
they have they wear something that
you're like what the [ __ ] is that like i
don't want to be their friend
um i don't know yeah and somebody that's
outgoing um has style you know stuff
stuff like that matters and somebody
that um i can uh like
find a middle ground with i guess okay i
didn't i didn't think all these girls
were as crazy as the girls they usually
bring on
because there were a couple girls in
there that didn't say like
six two six three and there were a bunch
of girls that didn't
like they said like below six figures
they would consider because
i swear half the girls they bring on the
show just
all think they're gonna date like
multi-millionaires
like i don't know but i thought this was
an interesting clip
um let me know what you guys think in
the comments and do not forget to
subscribe to the channel help me get to
20 000 subscribers and bring that
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next time